i want you to imagine a photograph
okay we're way up north in the canadian
arctic at a place called ellsmere island
this is a land where packs of white
arctic wolves prey on
oxen okay picture big shaggy buffalo
with thick curling horns
all right our photograph it shows what
happens
after a wolf kill the point of view is
from
inside the carcass of a dead musk ox
rib bones curve across the foreground
already picked clean
a wolf stares at the rest of the meat
we're so close that we can see
something in the wolf's eyes a primal
glint of determination
or maybe it's just hunger but
have you ever wondered how did a
photographer get that shot
and not get eaten wolf proof camera
traps
this is tom o'brien his business card
says he's a photo engineer at national
geographic
but really he's our photographer's
secret weapon
from his workshop in the national
geographic basement
tom designs completely custom camera
gear for our photographers
if you can dream it he can probably
build it the photographer on the wolf
assignment needed a camera that he could
place inside the carcass
and leave it there for days and i had to
think like a wolf
or like a dog because i was like well
dogs as we all know like to chew on
things right
and so they'll chew on the cables
they'll chew on the boxes right
after tom designed the camera trap he
protected all the cables with stainless
steel
but how could he be sure that an arctic
wolf couldn't actually bite through
i'll be honest with you at one point i
definitely like not on something
like all right could i get this nope you
nod on it you nod on your
camera trap on a stainless steel piece
of conduit i'm dead serious
i just kind of put in my mouth like no
definitely can't get to that because i
could stand on it and i couldn't bend it
and uh yeah i mean they came back with
no marks on the boxes
from the arctic wolf yeah
[Music]
tom in his photo engineering lab are the
secret sauce behind some of national
geographic's most surprising and iconic
images
so i wanted to know how does he do it
how does tom take a photographer's crazy
idea
and morph it into a custom camera that
looks like something out of a
transformers movie
and finally produce images that end up
in the pages of national geographic
i'm peter guinn editor-at-large at
national geographic
and this is overheard a show where we
eavesdrop on the wild conversations we
have here at netgeo
and follow them to the edges of our big
weird beautiful world
you've seen our magazine stunning photos
this week
we go behind the scenes in the workshop
that makes them possible
we'll follow our photo engineer as he
builds a contraption designed to
photograph something
that's never been seen before and in
honor of world oceans day
we'll explain the invention that helped
legendary explorer jacques cousteau
pull back the curtain on previously
unseen ocean landscapes
more after the break
tom spends a lot of time alone in his
lab
deep in the basement of national
geographic headquarters
he's surrounded by work benches and
large machines
with signs warning about electric shocks
and possible loss of limbs
and cameras lots and lots of cameras
for the most part what happens down
there only tom knows
hopefully i don't sound like too much of
a dum-dum while doing this
you guys said you want me to record
myself while i was working right
so uh there you go you get my train of
thought
inside my brain it's a crazy place
so we asked him to record a diary as he
started a new project this spring
this one it's all about beavers another
quick update
7 35 p.m march 1st
beaver lucian continues
okay we'll get to that one later as nat
geo's photo engineer
tom is always working on challenging
requests from photographers
the best way i can explain the job is
it's kind of a mash-up between
two brilliant fictional characters on
the one hand
tom is a little bit of cue from james
bond you know the inventor that crafted
all the elegant designs for 007 to use
out in the field
and on the other hand sometimes he's
macgyver you know
that guy racing against the clock to get
a handmade piece of tech out the door on
deadline
but whatever he's working on it's always
one of a kind
case in point and this is what i call
the funky bird drain
when tom holds the funky bird train in
front of me
it doesn't look very funky or really
anything like a bird
to my untrained eye it's just a little
metal box with a few pieces of pvc
pipe these days the funky bird train
sits on a shelf that kind of serves as
tom's hall of fame
funky bird train okay i'll tell you why
it's the funky bird train
so sage grouse it's a species of bird
that live out in the plains
of north america and they do a mating
dance in the morning the males do this
weird mating dance
and obviously a nat geo photographer
would want to see that weird mating
dance
it was actually charlie hamilton james
who we've met before on overheard
but it's not that easy sage grouse won't
dance if there's a human around
so charlie needed stealth and he asked
tom if he could build a little remote
control
train the camera would go on top of the
train and it could roll right into the
middle of the sage-grouse
and get the shot so we made the track
out of 3d printed railroad tires oh my
god and the track is
half inch standard plumbing pvc so he
could just pick that up out in wyoming
and then this is all this aluminum
little cart
fully rc controlled with a small camera
on it okay but a metallic remote control
train it's still going to scare the
birds right
so they needed to find a way to disguise
the camera
trolley made a paper mache sage-grouse
think kind of like a pinata
to cover everything up they cut a hole
so the camera could see
out and boom funky bird train ready to
roll
get into the mating dance oh and then
you can wi-fi control this
at 100 feet away and this little thing
kind of out on the prairie was like
city work yeah and the system totally
worked beautiful
in the end the funky bird train captured
a sage-grouse
and no less one bathed in the dramatic
light of a wyoming sunrise
it looks majestic standing straight up
with its tail feathers fanned out
and a thick ring of white feathers
around its neck kind of like a boa you
might wear to a fancy party
not bad for a bird known for being kind
of goofy or awkward
but without a photo engineer getting
that shot might not be possible
someone's been doing something like my
job since
probably early in the 1900s yeah
give or take i don't know when it
started exactly but like
it's been going on for a long time
someone's been doing weird custom stuff
at this address tom is the sole photo
engineer at national geographic
but he's part of a long line of
inventors who worked here before him
he calls them his ancestors and the
ancestors played a part in some of the
most
famous explorations of the 20th century
we're
very happy to have captain jacques eve
cousteau
with us tonight
[Applause]
[Music]
jacques cousteau in the 1950s he brought
the oceans to life in a whole new way
remember this was the height of the
space race
humans were obsessed with outer space
but cousteau believed the oceans were
just as vast a frontier
he called them inner space and they were
full of treasures
nobody had ever seen in 1960
cousteau spoke at national geographic
headquarters
he gave commentary as he played a film
he had taken on recent expeditions
like a rich thicket of plants all
growing together on the side of a
volcano
a thousand feet below the surface no
human eye has ever seen
such gardens before
these gardens are far below the rich
beyond the reach of divers
of course at the time everybody wasn't
walking around with smartphones in their
pockets
and capturing photos and film underwater
was an extremely specialized skill
requiring a lot of technical know-how
and expensive equipment
so not just anybody could do this on the
one hand
cousteau is allowing viewers for the
first time to see sharks and whales up
close
and creatures they've never even seen
before but on the other hand
he's giving scientists a powerful new
tool to explore this poorly understood
landscape
like when during this presentation
cousteau's camera
narrowed on a group of brittle star
relatives of sea stars
standing at attention on the sea floor
like a troop of salters
or a forest the regularity of this
forest
astonished the biologists
so imagine the value of such documents
taken for hours and hours but cousteau
didn't capture these images alone
he relied on one of tom o'brien's
ancestors
harold edgerton here at the right you
recognize
our friend dr harold edgerton
who has always been with us
in the interesting experiments made
most of the ocean is pitch black and in
the 1950s photographers struggled to
light underwater photos
sometimes water pressure would even
shatter old school flash bulbs
so the photographer ended up with just a
handful of broken glass
and no good photos to show for it so
edgerton took on the challenge
he specialized in creating strobe
lighting techniques
he was so well known for it that
cousteau's crew called him papa flash
with funding from national geographic
edgerton invented a new type of lighting
system
and new cameras to capture high quality
underwater images
he and cousteau would attach the cameras
and lights to a sled
called a troika and then tow it through
the water dr edgerton
asks for one of his
gadgets to be bolted on the toy car
this time it's going to be a very
special electronic flash
especially designed for a movie camera
with the new cameras cousteau's dreams
came to life
he made us see the ocean the way he saw
it
as a fragile spectacular world and more
importantly
he made us care scientists credit
cousteau with
jolting the public into action for
generations of scientists
conservationists but also millions of
regular people including me and my
brothers
gawking at the television in our living
room cousteau helped us
see the hidden world inside the ocean
and realized that we had to protect it
none of that could have happened without
an engineer tinkering and discovering a
better way to capture those images
and now more than 60 years later that's
the legacy tom o'brien carries on
[Music]
besides diving with jacques cousteau
national geographic photo engineers have
worked on all sorts of projects
some more far-fetched than others they
actually designed gear to help search
for the loch ness monster
which they did not find they've also
attached the camera to the tail of a
jumbo jet
used super high-speed cameras to study
the biomechanics of a cheetah
taken aerial photos of machu picchu from
a blimp
and photographed a bullet in flight so
you get the idea
i went to visit tom in his subterranean
lair he loves to give tours
now this is the probably one of the best
parts of the entire tour
one second tom shows me a weird skinny
camera
he's not sure but he thinks it may have
been used to photograph the inside of an
egyptian tomb
and then he tells me about a camera he
made for free solo the oscar-winning
documentary
the filmmaker jimmy chin captured
climber alex honold
scaling el capitan with no ropes one day
out of the blue jimmy called tom
and he explained there's this hard part
where alex didn't want cameras well he
or alex didn't want people being here
yeah
right and said and i told me like when
they were going to try to do
the climbs and so i built them three
cameras
um three camera systems so in the film
when alex clears one of the trickiest
sections
called the boulder problem that's tom
and you get absolute terrible vertigo
with that shot
oh my gosh no thank you
i'm decent with heights but not like
that yeah okay so blimps
tombs funky bird train and tom's
workshop if you can imagine
an image he can come up with a
contraption to capture it
this spring we got when that tom was
actually starting a new project
it's called you guessed it evolution
uh 7 26 p.m
still at the office it's march 1st of
course it's 20 21.
the beaver lucian idea came from one of
tom's repeat customers
ronan donovan he's the photographer who
captured the arctic wolves we heard
about at the beginning
and he wants to do a specific image in a
way that hasn't been done before
ronan wants to photograph the way
beavers store food under the ice in
winter
as far as national geographic staff can
tell ronan would be the first person to
ever capture that image
so how's he gonna do it
ronan plans to camp out at a frozen
beaver pond
he'll chainsaw a hole in the ice and
stick a camera down the hole
into the water and it's a tricky thing
to do remote cameras underwater
because well our starter sits under
water and
cameras don't like water so here's what
tom has to do
first he has to protect the camera in
the cold icy water
he also has to create some kind of frame
that sits on the ice
with the camera hanging down into the
water and then
he has to fine-tune specialized cables
for power
lighting and for ronan to control the
camera oh and
by the way he has less than a month to
slap together the beaver cam
before the winter ice melts and i've
done some of this before
but it's uh it's a nice challenge for
once to uh
get a weird one this is gonna be fun
okay so here we go after tom sketches
out a plan
he orders as much of the gear off the
shelf as he can find on the internet
in about a week after our first update
tom gets a package
so we're just gonna open a box
what are we doing we're gonna open up a
brand new underwater housing
that arrived today
what do we got in the box lots of
packing peanuts
in the box all right oh my god
tom unwraps a black box with a glass
dome bulging out of the middle it looks
like the outer shell of a camera
and has lots of little levers and
buttons inside
this is an underwater camera housing
it's a little astronaut suit that keeps
the camera dry and warm underwater
and it's ready to go out of the box but
tom wants to make a few
small modifications so that it works
with the rest of the equipment he's
making
that's the name of the game is reverse
engineering things that are off the
shelf
modifying them and sticking them back on
the field photographers and we hope for
the best
all right oh those are wobbly so we're
gonna need
that size bolt cool cool
let's take off another one of these
come on get off
thankfully no tools or knuckles were
broken in the making of this episode
they put this on really hard oh they
really didn't
wow that is on in tight
i'm about to break a tool doing this
what the heck i'll be right back
okay so tom eventually got the bolt off
and
underwater housing check next he needs a
way to anchor the camera above the ice
so that it can hang down into the water
he plans a simple metal frame
about the size and shape of a basic
workbench you might have in your garage
the frame's feet will stay on the icy
surface of the pond
and after ronin cuts a hole the camera
will hang down into the water from the
middle of the frame
it kind of looks like a swing set if a
swing set had a gigantic lens staring at
you in the face
not only does tom have to make the frame
but he has to fabricate the little metal
pieces to keep the camera attached
we're going to do some cutting a balloon
we're going to do some welding i think
of stainless steel
probably some eating of pizza while
walking around the shop
very sanitary here we go
by now he has just days to finish the
frame and get everything shipped out
he's super busy welding milling cutting
assembling and testing
but when i visited i couldn't resist
getting him to show me the coolest tool
he's got
the plasma cutter
plasma is the fourth type of matter
i mean like former matter you know
you've got
solids liquids gases and then you have
plasma we're not going to go to nutshell
it's like a lightsaber it's like the
closest thing on earth to a lightsaber
and it's
fantastic
yeah i totally know what i'm asking for
for father's day
after tom finishes all the little
touches on the metal frame
he starts working on all the cables okay
this is tedious work
but it looks like he's gonna meet the
deadline it's almost like a sprint
because there's just days left and
it's just me i can't be like hey you
friend can you come help there's no
friend to come out
as tom raced to get the beaver cam
finished i started to wonder about the
end result
the photographs what would these beaver
photographs look like and
after all this work what will readers in
national geographic magazine actually
see
you know ronan will set this up how many
images do you think will come out of
this will actually end up
either in the magazine or online one one
published photograph
that's what all this is for so why do
you go to all the trouble for
one published photograph the answer to
that question lies with the people who
decide what goes into the magazine
the photo editors we have been doing
a few digital like short
digital stories on fevers very specific
uh and i would always be
pulling my hair out trying to find a
decent photograph
this is kaya byrne she's a photo editor
on our animal's desk
this beaver story is her brain child
the nat geo photo archive is gargantuan
something like 11 and a half million
photos
and for an in-depth story photo editors
like kaya regularly look through tens of
thousands of frames
looking for the one image that stands
out from the rest
kaya says she can count on one hand the
number of good beaver photos
photos that seem intimate or give you a
glimmer of the animal's personality
every other beaver photograph out there
really is not good it's it's typically
taken from above the water
so you have horrible reflection so i was
just getting frustrated
she thought if there aren't any good
beaver photos
we're national geographic we should go
make some so she planned a whole story
including the shot tom's beavercam is
designed for
seeing beavers underneath winter ice i
mean they are
probably second to us when it comes to
knowing how to engineer
in their environment so being able to
actually show that
right underwater middle of winter
food of food stock that they you know
put together throughout the summer and
fall
for themselves so kaya wants her story
to show how beavers
interact with the natural world and how
they interact with us
it all starts with seeing an
extraordinary side of nature
jacques does showed us that seeing is
the first step to pushing people to
protect it
if cousteau could make us care about
what's hidden beneath the oceans
why not beavers i think that you know if
you can
create some feeling within a person
of maybe not empathy but connection
and similarity in a way
you can then get them to care about that
animal
[Music]
back in his lab tom is near the finish
line with the beaver cam
so it's 4 33 p.m on tuesday
march 23rd of 2021 and i've got a bit of
an update for everyone
as in all things in life things can
change
he's almost ready to ship it out and
then he gets a phone call
so going into this morning it was all go
go go go
full commando mode full mcgyver mode
just
figure it out it's hard and as fast as i
could so we could try to get this thing
shipped out later this week
but projects like this have a lot of
moving parts and the photographer
ronan tells tom there's been a delay he
won't make it into the field before the
ice melts so
the beaver cam won't see action just yet
there will be no triumphant send up of
all the gear at the end
tom says it was disappointing to get
that call but he was also relieved
you know as an engineer any real any
true engineer no one wants to run i
don't like that i rush
i have to rush projects so when you get
more time all of a sudden you're like
okay
first off i can go take a nap okay great
secondly
i can take time to work out all the
problems okay there was one upside
since the beavercam was delayed i
actually got to see it in person
and there's really only one feature that
dominates your attention
the glass dome of the underwater housing
with the camera peering out
so this looks to me like a giant robot
eye
it's big black unblinking scary
this is big brother right this is it's
close enough i mean
and that's an interesting for now that
unblinking robot eye sits in tom's
workshop
waiting for its chance to capture
beavers like we've never seen them
before
but already tom is dreaming up new uses
for the beaver cam
for one he plans to reuse it with other
photographers
and other projects beyond beavers and he
also sees some more possibilities to
bring beavers to life
so in theory with this i can now
sorry this is all very exciting my brain
we could
make a zoom call or like a video call
conference call on his computer
and then have the footage be direct from
an underwater
view of a beaver dam that's right beaver
lucian
live stream straight from the dam and
maybe you would see a
beaver swimming by or something like
that that's crazy i just thought about
that
we're gonna have to try this and even
though the beaver cam is finished
there's plenty of day-to-day craziness
he's also a one-man help
hotline for our photographers at any
time he could get a call in the middle
of the night from
india or an update from an explorer
stranded on an iceberg
so i mean you know it's always exciting
every day's exciting natural you never
know what screwball thing
some photographer or visual journalist
is going to come up with next be like
hey
so i got an idea can we do this
and whenever those ideas come up we have
a guy actually
our secret weapon and with that i sign
off for now
[Music]
goodbye
all right so if all this talk about
photography has you fired up
check out the show notes we have plenty
of photos of arctic wolves the sage
grouse as captured by the funky bird
train
and a super slo-mo of cheetah running at
top speed you gotta check this out it's
crazy
also for world oceans day learn more
about the legendary jacques cousteau
he pioneered scuba diving brought the
ocean to our living rooms
and sparked people to protect the world
around us
and even though the beavercam photos
haven't published yet
we have a really cool story about
beavers and how they change the world
around us
it's a previous episode of overheard
called march of the beavers some of you
may have already heard it
go listen again it's awesome check it
out in your feed
or in the show notes they're right there
in your podcast app and while you're
there
be sure to rate and review us in apple
podcasts it really helps other listeners
find us
overheard at national geographic is
produced by jacob pinter
brian gutierrez laura sim alana strauss
and manika wilhelm our senior producer
is carla wills
our senior editor is eli chen our
executive
producer of audio's d'var artelon our
fact checkers are robin palmer and julie
beer
our copy editor is amy kolczak hansdale
sue composed our theme music and
engineers our episodes
thanks to karen circa for archival
research and for providing the recording
of jacques cousteau heard in this
episode
this podcast is a production of national
geographic partners
whitney johnson is the director of
visuals and immersive experiences
susan goldberg is national geographic's
editorial director
and i'm your host peter gwynne thanks
for listening and see y'all next time
[Music]
you